when a conservative speaks on a college
campus
anything can happen
We're Not Gonna
outrage boiling over at the University
of Buffalo
ism is a call for genocide
hundreds of students and community
members gathered in protest
[Music]
do you have anything else to say
chanting picketing in some even needing
police restraint you wanna tell me why I
should leave because transphobia is beta
behavior and you are a Beta male you
should leave
so what would cause a liberal Lynch Mob
to attempt to shut me down and
intimidate attendees before I utter to
work
[Music]
my producer attempted to find out why so
many people seemed hell-bent on keeping
me out what brings you out here today
um there is a extremist speaker that is
speaking at UB tonight I have some like
transgender friends and they were really
hurt by like a lot of the the news and
like a lot of like what was happening I
wanted to like stand with my community I
think you just perpetuate hate towards
lots of people that don't deserve it oh
I'm sorry you feel that way but I think
you're mistaken this many people are
here because they don't believe in that
hate they don't want to continue the
hate we're here because we want to drown
out the noise that he's making have you
ever watched one of Michael Knowles's
speeches or seen his show in its
entirety not just like one of the clips
I have not no I don't need to though
college students are often uninformed
that's why they're in college they're
supposed to get educated but it seems
they all had the same reason for hating
me specifically for the good of society
and especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely I have seen some of
his comments about the trans Community
specifically saying that trans people
should be eradicated from our
communities you shouldn't be saying that
they should be eradicated if you have
never been in their shoes can I just
tell you we're not gonna
eradicate anyone
you guys I don't want to eradicate
anybody either
[Music]
now where could they have gotten that
idea numerous headlines after this
speech said he wants to get rid of
transgender people basically just
calling for the eradication of trans
people literally calling for a genocide
genocidal call what else could you
possibly mean besides getting rid of
those people now that was all news to me
I never considered myself a particularly
genocidal kind of guy but that's what
the news said almost as if the entire
liberal establishment had been
intentionally lying about what I said
the University Administration dug in its
heels and did nothing to correct the
record before my speech instead the
administrators doubled down on the
defamation unfortunately the university
only allowed 300 people to come listen
to this speech even though about 1 000
people tried to get tickets now among
those who got in there were a lot who
liked what I had to say but there were
even a few who came in prepared to
disagree with me and they sat down not
just to hear the speech but sat down
opposite me to hash out our differences
in person when one calls to eradicate
cancer one is not suggesting that we
ought to murder the cancer patients so
how do these liberal news editors come
up with their headline that I wanted to
commit a genocide
transgender people Freedom itself
cannot exist Without Limits the question
before us is not how free our society
ought to be but rather what will
delineate the limits of freedom
Becca
thank you for sitting down of course
Camilla carime thank you for sitting
down you were outside of the auditorium
with the protesters of this speech why
were you protesting me I was genuinely
wondering how a man is going to explain
how radical feminism is hurting women
did I convince you no no no not really
no I think you
brought up some
good points on like how there are
certain types of feminism that aren't
great because there's always a radical
something that's not good it's always
going too far and doing too little I saw
your like poster also and I was like oh
it's just like you know like another
speaker just coming in and like talking
and then I started seeing like
transgenderism should be eradicated and
as you know eradicated is it's a big
word you know and yeah it's five
syllables
yeah but you know it could like be taken
into like different things like you know
like to destroy and everything like that
and like to get rid of which I think
that's where you were going with that is
very much get rid of yeah yeah I have
some like transgender friends and they
were really hurt by like a lot of the
the news and like a lot of like what was
happening I wanted to like stand with my
community my argument is not as some
newspaper is very irresponsibly reported
that I want to you know exterminate
people or something but my argument is
that this whole idea of transgenderism
is pretty new you both have friends who
identify in this way there are many more
people right who say I am transgender
and so my question is why are so many
more people saying that now you said
that like this like being transgender is
this new ideology yeah it's not um
there's evidence of people who were
transgender in ancient Greece Rome
Judaism is an example of a religion that
acknowledges I think six or seven
genders I don't think that's quite true
and and my evidence for that would be in
the in the very first book of the Torah
in the in Genesis one of the most
prominent lines is that in the beginning
God created man both male and female
created heathens it's not the but
Judaism
um I think what the original translation
I can't set my source right now okay but
um they from what I've learned going to
different like religious schools is that
just synagogues temples I've tried and
like experienced different religions
they said that the original text said
Adam and Eve as in one being one well
man yeah man so uh in the earliest
chapters of Genesis you have the
creation of man in Adam and then Eve is
Created from Adam's Rib but she would be
the other sex what you're citing is this
line that a lot of people who are
pro-transgender will say which is you
know actually in some Native American
tribe that I can't quite name right now
I'm sure they believe in a third and a
fourth and a fifth gender but that just
isn't true that is a that's been made up
by white liberals you know the movie
Mulan Disney Disney I haven't seen it
but I've heard of it just as the man
right goes to war that's based off of
true history oh yes cross-dressing
did the female character think she was a
man no oh okay
why there's so many spikes and like
people saying that they're transgender
is because people are much more
comfortable now like going out and
saying that they're like transgender
because they know that there now is like
that community that will accept them
what if they're not really comfortable
though there's a guy who pioneered the
transgender surgery at Johns Hopkins his
name is Dr Paul McHugh and he created
the gender identity clinic and he gave
these experimental surgeries to men who
thought they were women and he ended up
shutting it down because he said people
were not more satisfied in the long run
after the surgery is it possible that
people expressing this transgender
identity is not really making them all
that happy
female so my my aunt
she was never
than she was after she experiences so
she's
happy like she's living her life now
that she's transitioned I've in you know
it's like you never know like what if
they can't feel that way if they stayed
how they were do you think that the
person you now call your Aunt do you
think that
I would say he really is a she really is
a woman or is it just kind of a little
bit of a white lie that we all tell to
make this person feel better
no I thought I think it is you know like
I think they actually are like female
you know I think there's just some
people out there that are just born in
the wrong in the wrong bodies can can I
ask you a question please
do you have kids yeah hypothetically
right saying like if your kids want to
transition and they
um tell you like they don't they don't
feel like how they yeah
um how would you respond well I I would
hope that the likelihood of that
happening would be greatly diminished
because I would not be raising them in a
culture that would encourage him and so
we do see it even if you think that
there is a biological component to this
gender identity ideology we do see that
in communities and ages that are more
encouraging of it you see the numbers of
gender identity
cases Skyrocket so I think the fact that
we're raising our children in a more
traditional kind of environment would at
least reduce the possibility more than
one in five Zoomers identifies as lgbtq
Plus
that's a that's about a tenfold increase
over the general population so obviously
this is catching on because now they can
one in five people is just born that way
you don't think there's any social
contagion I again can't cite the exact
Source in my biology class here in the
school we learned that there are some
biological indicators for gay men they
have a smaller gland in their brain that
shows up on scans even if that were the
case that wouldn't that wouldn't uh
change the way that we necessarily ought
to behave the way that we were born does
not imply that we are slaves to our
nature because human beings unlike the
lower animals have intellect and will
and so because we have a rational will
we can actually curb some of our
appetites and bring them into Accord
with our rational will which is
conscious let's say God forbid that you
know my kid has any problems one of
which is he struggles with his view of
sex or gender probably what I would tell
him is hey love you buddy you know
um but this is reality and so I would
try to to ballast my kids or any loved
one that I have in the truth because
there's a great quote from C.S Lewis on
this he says if you look for truth you
might find comfort in the end but if you
look for comfort you will find neither
truth nor Comfort only soft soap and
Wishful Thinking to begin and in the end
despair despair because you got nothing
to hold on to other than your own
fleeting passions I have lots of trans
friends you have lots of friends who
think they're the opposite sex I have
lots of friends
what what if they're wrong
what if what if what if you're wrong
about being straight I guess I would
still behave as though I was straight my
view of sex and gender is that our true
sexuality and our true gender is not
from some deep deeply hidden and
authentic appetite that might be
invisible to the public but is actually
prescribed according to our human nature
but who are you to tell people that
they're wrong well I'm a man with reason
and the moral conscience I am a woman
with reason and I think it's not my
place to tell somebody that what they're
feeling is wrong you just told me that
I'm wrong about transgenderism
I'm saying how we all choose to live is
our business because we live in society
why isn't my business if somebody
identifies as a woman or not well
because right now women are allowed to
have their own bathrooms and if a man is
allowed to identify as a woman in public
women are not allowed to have them you
know a man can just walk into the
bathroom at any time right but he'll be
arrested in a normal society and in our
society he can he could sue if he were
kicked out of the women's bathroom
orange is identifying as trans to look
up girls skirts well some people are
some people there are problems well
there was a pretty prominent crime in
Loudoun County where a high school
student who wore skirts and identified
as a gender ambiguous would go into the
girls room and he raped two girls at two
different schools and it was covered up
because of the transgender ideologies I
can't swear that's messed up it's messed
up um it's messed up I agree right one
example but to to generalize that to all
I'm not opposed to transgenderism
because I think some individual who
thinks he's transgender is a really
rotten fella in fact I'm I'm only
opposed to transgenders because of the
general fact that a man can become a
woman and a woman can't become a man
because I can know that to be true and
if I can't know that to be true
objectively then I can't really know
much of anything at all right they
choose you know to go through those
transformations in order to like feel
like their soul and their body actually
like is the idea that
your true identity is your soul and your
body is only incidental to that that you
you know because to even say your true
identity I think well your true identity
is got something to do with your body I
think I don't think I think the only
thing your true identity has nothing to
do with your body right yeah we are we
are our souls and I think um well
growing up in a Catholic Church I think
of myself as my soul and I think that my
my body you know it's my flesh it's
temporary are you still Catholic would
you say no no because you know the
Catholic ideas yes of course we are
souls in part but we are also bodies and
our bodies and souls have a lot to do
with one another and they're Inseparable
so you know the Catholic I do would be
to say that your soul is in
contradicting your body that wouldn't
you could that wouldn't that would not
go along with the Catholic idea and it
it's very interesting that there's this
new maybe religious view which is that
no our bodies that's not has nothing to
do with our true selves that view is
called gnosticism Gnostic dualism that
we're really our souls in the body is is
evil or something like that but I just
wonder how do we know that's true how do
you know that you're not really at least
in part your body
they always say mind over body you know
because your your brain you know it
it's the thing that controls like
everything you know like
sends off like these signals and but
your brain is your body too your mind is
not your body you know that's that's the
immaterial part but the brain is part of
your body it's an organ right
well yeah my primary problem with
transgenderism is that it isn't true and
because it's false there are harmful
consequences from it they're not doing
any harm to you yeah well I think that
sexual dysfunctions caused a lot of harm
the breakdown of the family the
obliteration of women's rights in
private spaces the mutilation of
children which now we're seeing just
abound in the country the sterilization
of children so I think there are a lot
of pretty did you know that hormone
therapy is made was made for like girls
who get their periods at the age of six
you can go on estrogen and it will go
back it doesn't that's what they tell
you but it's not true and there are a
lot of detransitioners who talk about
the the
lifelong effects on okay but it's not
de-transitions women who have male
pattern baldness and a lowered voice for
the rest of their life and who are
sterile too I mean that's pretty that's
tough you can't yeah okay I probably
can't have kids either I have PCOS so
what do you think we should sterilize
more children
it's all sterilizing kids no that is we
were just talking about it's really not
though it's it's stopping them from
going through puberty where they don't
want to I guess maybe we're just using
different terms for this probably but in
any case I appreciate your uh you're
coming on oh I have something for you I
found it outside I thought you'd really
like it does this a uh a fan letter oh
it is yeah yeah
there's a lot of this right radical
feminism did ruin my life and it's me
dressed up as a as an official from the
Biden Administration I think yeah
able to change the minds of these young
students but they came they listened and
they had a conversation so maybe just
maybe I was able to plant a seed that
could flourish in the future that's
thanks to Young America's Foundation
which puts on these campus events these
students at least were willing to come
in and listen not just spend the whole
evening shouting outside so perhaps down
the line those seeds of knowledge will
flourish we can hope and we can hope
that more students will be willing to
cross that picket line at Future campus
events we'll see you there